e
[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on programmed
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of
disease and now the Superstar of
Alternative Health and purveyor of
medical truth Dr Joel
[Music]
wallik hello and welcome to Dead Doctors
Don't Lie Dr Joel wallik your host a
veterinarian and physician and I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to die at 75.5 like your
parents and grandparents I'm here for
kids and baby boomers and seniors who
don't want to be sick and miserable for
the last 15 to 20 years of their life
like their parents and grandparents I am
a conservative a lot of people say I
treat them like dogs but they do seem to
get better now you have a personal
Health Challenge you want to ask about
if you have a health challenge of a
friend a loved one a workmate or if you
want to talk about medical politics at
the homebased business opportunity give
us a call toll-f
free8 379 2552 again that's toll
2552 well today we need to ask the
ultimate question why are our Foods so
deficient particularly in mineral
well um I was kind of learning that back
as a kid growing up in the farm every
morning had to throw the wood ashes out
of the wood stove into the garden for
fertilizer one of my
chores and so that was just something I
just did every day and asked why well
it's good fertilizer for the plants okay
that's that's what it's all about um got
into agricultural school at the
University of Missouri and my saws
Professor was William alre one of the
one of the guys who really figured out
that our s were depleted of minerals and
he was coming up with big projects to
grind up mountains and replenish the
fields with mineral dust by grinding up
mountains well of course it was
obscenely expensive project but he knew
that the soils were deficient minerals
and his idea was to grind up Boulders
and put the minerals back in the thing
and he was a an organic farmer he was
really extremely well respected I spent
a lot of time with him my Sal Professor
William Al University of
Missouri then when you kind of go back
and you look at
history you go back and you look at the
big Rivers look at the big rivers in the
world and the cultures that they
generated the na River and of course
Egypt the Ganges River in India um and
then you look at the voldo river in
Russia and the Ry River in Germany and
the TS River in England you look at the
Amazon River and the countries in South
America and you begin to see that
there's there's all these big cultures
they're creative they're inventive
they're powerful they bu armies and they
can sustain great cultures and and
cities around these Great Rivers what
was kind of a common threat well they
would all flood in the spring when the
flood waters Reed they leave silt behind
and still at this time everybody's using
wood as a universal fuel around the
world and throwing the wood ashes which
turn out to be minerals not really ashes
95 to 98% of the wood ashes are really
the powder just minerals and just a
couple percentage points are unburnt
carbon and so we see that this powder
turns gray or black which gave people
the idea it was ashes whatever that
meant instead of
minerals
and so there's all this going on in my
mind and let's see here I knew that when
I was nine years old I had Tourette
Syndrome would be called tette syndrome
today doctors couldn't fix it I just
read some things in in a nurse's
handbook about cramping and that sort of
stuff and it was due to counsel
deficiency started eating animal food in
five years I got worse and worse wor
worse till I was debilitated with this
threat syndrome for 5 years and in 3
days time I cured Myself by eating
animal Al Alpha pels meant for beef
cattle calves okay and so I'm learning
about all these minerals and how how you
can might not be in your food you have a
supplement all right so what else do we
learn well George Washington
Carver um a slave was actually um
learning that he could fertilize
um Gardens and Fields by taking the silt
out of the rivers actually harvesting
the silt out of the river not waiting
for floods and putting the silt in the
rivers he was also putting wood ash in
the gardens okay and he started tus gige
Institute the agricultural school for
the black community George Washington
caror and then um there's a guy uh by
the name of Weston Price He was a
dentist this dentist Weston Price um
would he just loved to go to the Pacific
Islands and vacation this is way before
the SE second world war 1920s and
30s and he's taking pictures of the
dental arches of these children there
that just look beautiful kids round
faces they had perfect Dental arches
their third world cultures and he was
just so fascinated by that and after the
second world war a year after the second
world war ended he goes back and starts
vacations again and lo and behold all
their Dental arches are now messed up
and they needed orthodonics work they
needed braces straighten out their teeth
before they didn't need that and he went
back and he looked he said oh they're
actually fertilizing their garden with
these wood
ashes and
um he he didn't pay attention to that
but what he thought was that this
happened because prior to the uh Second
World War people were actually uh eating
their food raw and weren't fertilizing
with what you know he he didn't pay
attention to the wood ashes thing but he
was noticing that they were eating food
raw that's what he thought he that
they're eating their food raw it was his
big thing then after the second world
war they were cooking their food well
they were cooking their food before the
second world war but they were using
wood for fuel and putting the wood ash
in the garden Driftwood wood from their
own trees there on the islands um
coconut husk as fuel and putting the
ashes into their Gardens well after the
second world war everybody had
electricity on the islands that he was
going to they had generated electricity
with generators and diesel fuel um
that propane tanks and he attributed to
cooking the food well he was close but
it was cooking with electricity and
propane that caused all the degenerate
bone disease in these kids these Pacific
Islands his observations were documented
perfectly with pictures before and after
but his interpretation what was
happening was wrong well I want you to
contact your young Dy associate get the
book epigenetics The Death of the
genetics 3 transmission the book Dead
doors don't lie the book earth ventur
goes into all these nutritional
deficiencies particularly mineral
nutritional deficiencies that wind up
causing muscular skeletal things
arthritis osteoprosis things like lupus
um things like muscularis
sosis right again that's epigenetics
dead d l rare
or you can solber p you got a supplement
don't forget the 90 essential nutrients
we'll be back with dead do and life for
these
messag you're listening to Dead Doctors
Don't Lie on the zbs radio network with
your host Dr Joel wallik if you'd like
to talk to Dr wallik today call us on
the priority line 831 68510 80 toll-free
888 379
[Music]
2552 when those aches and pains in your
knees elbows hands shoulders and back
crop up reach reach for young jeevi CM
cream put CM cream on a Q-tip and put it
in your ear canal for relief from
headaches and sinus pressure a topical
temporary relief from minor aches and
pains of muscles and Joints associated
with strains sprains and simple
backaches why take aspirin or
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
that can cause stomach bleeding and
liver damage just apply CM cream
liberally to the affected areas and
within 20 minutes or so you'll have
relief from those nagging minor aches
and pains you'll feel better for up to 4
to 5 hours so the next time you have
achy joints or muscles do what I do
reach for CM cream for Relief and for
systemic relief reach for CM plus
capsules if you'd like to learn more
about nutritional supplementation call
your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about homebased
business opportunities in recent years
several studies have discovered the
healthy benefits of drinking coffee
youngevity has now taken it a step
further with an entire product line of
healthy coffees from youngevity's java
fit selection of topshelf gourmet
coffees all Java fit coffees are made
from 100% premium hand selected araba
coffee beans grown in the finest regions
of Latin America all are carefully
roasted creating a delicious Rich
full-bodied flavor for an extra boost
try Java fits energy extreme 62 a
proprietary blend of nutrients including
Cambo oia green tea extract an extra
shot of caffeine and niin designed to
support metabolism and enhance physical
performance available in single cup or
single pot packs contact your local
youngevity distributor to get jav
luution coffees and don't forget to ask
about the homebased business
[Music]
opportunity
we're back with dead doline of zbs radio
network Dr wer for Youngy 9 FL Crusade
we do have lines open give us a call
toll-f free8 379 2552 again that's
toll-free 1 tri8 379
2552 and if you need to lose that 10 25
50 75 100 pounds or more contact your
Young D associate and as for the books
Hell's Kitchen the subtitle is the cause
r obesity it also discusses type
diabetes and the metabolic syndrome and
the book energy
crisis okay and these two books will
tell you why people are overweight and
obese lack of nutrients is really what
it is particularly mineral nutrients and
it tells you how to supplement properly
to lose a half a pound to two pounds a
day and of course we have the keto
caramel Shake we have the keto caramel
bar meal replacer 251 calories uh puts
your body in the mode where it's going
to burn your fat it's going to burn your
body fat and help speed up the process
you lose a half a pound to two pounds a
day and the magic is you'll never gain
the weight back as long as you continue
taking the 90 essential nutrients and
the Rev R EV which is an accelerator and
you lose a half a pound or two pounds a
day it's not unusual It's Not Unusual
okay to lose that half a pound two
pounds a day and never gain it back I
don't care if you need to lose 300 400
500 pounds we can help you lose a half a
pound or two pounds a day and you you
will be magic person we do this
thousands of times a month why not you
okay Doug what pros of wisdom do you
have for us well they're at it again
I've got a CBS news story here headlined
more than one in five emergency room
patients face quote surprise medical
bills according to a study which comes
from John's Hopkins they found a lot of
patients getting socked with unexpected
bills despite making sure that they got
treatment at hospitals in their
insurance Network a specific case was
Rihanna shade rushed her five-month-old
daughter Daisy to an emergency room
after a seizure the daughter's fine but
then she was unexpectedly hit with an
anesthesiology bill for almost
$33,000 she says at no point in time
were we ever notified that the
anesthesiologist didn't participate in
our plan or were we given any kind of
choice schlade is not alone as more than
one and five emergency room patients
face what are called surprise medical
bills even though they thought they were
in network in the hospital they were
being treated and then build by out of
network Physicians a study found that
the of the largest increases in that
Medicare price include charges for
emergency medicine anesthesiology and
Radiology they say often these surprise
bills are coming from what we call on
ologists according to church bell the
programs director for Consumers Union
says you have states around this country
where over 50% of the emergency doctors
are out of network at in network
hospitals handful of States like New
York and Connecticut have uh past
legislation limiting a patient's
liability for outof Network care and for
sheade she's still fighting the bill and
trying to sort it out with the insurance
company and the provider and she said
I've spent hours and hours and hours on
the phone with the provider the
insurance company appeal after appeal
has been denied they say your primary
care provider if you have one can be
your your Advocate with an insurance
company or health care facility and say
in this CA any case consumers unions can
offer state-by-state tools for getting
helped just search Consumer Reports
Insurance complaint online so there you
go yes well again there's no oversight
of any kind for the medical community
and so there's nobody who checks their
Billings nobody who checks their ethics
when it comes to finances nobody checks
their diagnosis compared to the lab work
and as a result they have built a
community of Fraud and actually taking
advantage of the patient uh you never
hear of a doctor losing his house for
lack of money right you never hear of a
doctor not being able to afford the
horrible tuitions for their children
right that's because they can call in
three or four or five people and do
procedures on them they really don't
need just to get the money to pay the
bills and nobody pays attention to this
there's no oversight and if I were
insurance companies I'd gather together
they lobbying saying look we need to be
checking how these doctors figure out
their billing uh how they make their
diagnosis and so forth because there's
too much graft and prod involved here
and so insurance company should have
somebody that can look at every doctor's
records like once every three months and
kind of keep an eye on these guys
because they have certainly turned
Americans into an ATM machine so I urge
everybody to get a hold of that trilogy
of books Let's play doctor let's play
herbal doctor the passport Roma therapy
learn how to do your own physicals you
can do a $2,000 physical for $4.50 you
can get all the test stps um that a
doctor will use from a pharmacy without
a
prescription don't
forget let's play doctor let's herbal
doctor and passport Grom therapy start
doing all this stuff yourself and tell
the doctors to go to the bank if they
want an ATM machine and we'll be back
with Dead Doctors Don't Lie for these
messages you're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network with your host Dr Joel wallik if
you have questions for Dr Wall call us
between dude and one Pacific at 83168
5108 tollfree 888 379
[Music]
2552 many believe that all life began in
the earth's oceans we do know that the
oceans and seas are still abundant with
life and life- sustaining nutrients many
cultures have long believed in the
life-giving properties of plants and sea
life harvested from the oceans young
jabes oceans gold is a proprietary blend
of seaweeds algae mosses kelp sea
cucumbers and sea minerals as well as
co-enzyme Q10 calcium and iron all
designed to help support healthy thyroid
function regular heartbeat normal weight
mood stabilization and hormone levels
take advantage of life- sustaining
nutrients from the Earth's oceans with
youngevity oceans gold if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about homebased business
opportunities hello Judy dilus here if I
could only afford to get one product out
of everything that product would be the
ultimate classic it has the vitamins the
minerals the bioflavonoids it even has
grape seed extract the one product that
would give you just about everything
under the sun you would need for a
perfect nutritional program would be the
ultimate classic by the way people that
are on the go it's very very hard to
take the liquids with them when they go
on their trip to get their supplements
in every day well you know something you
can use the ultimate daily tablets and
the mineral capsules when I'm going on a
trip if I have enough room I just take
the two bottles with me if not just use
a little baggie and take a couple of
daily doses with you it's very simple
it's very easy there's no mess no fuss
no Refrigeration just take your capsules
take your tablets and you're finished
for the day to order these products call
your local youngevity distributor
today you've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel wallik helped many
people on the dead doctor don't lie talk
radio program you've also heard hundreds
of people tell how Dr wallik and
youngevity products have changed their
lives if you're now convinced that Dr
wallik is on to something and you want
to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313 444
3463 that's 313 444
3463 call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 313 444
3463 that's 313 444 3463 call now to
change your life that's 313 444
[Music]
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the zbs radio network Dr Joel wall here
for young 9:00 we do have lines open
call toll free8 37925 52 again that's
toll free18 379
2552 if you're going to do the young
jity business as a business I urge you
to get a hold of that trilogy of books
Let's play doctor let's pay herbal
doctor in the passport growing therapy
and learn how to deal with over 900
different diseases using vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals in rare
Earths amino acids fatty acids herbs and
roma therapy ISS that's a Trilogy of
books Let's play doctor let's play
herbal doctor in the passport froma
therapy and of course the added benefit
is but also be able to learn how to do
your own physicals and save yourself
thousands and thousands of dollars every
year save yourself from getting your
insurance rates going up because a
doctor diagnoses with something and
calls it genetic or autoimmune or famal
whereas you can diagnose it yourself
using the books let us play doctor let
us play herbal Doctrine password ROM
therapy and you can learn in those books
how to diagnose them how to manage them
how to help your body get rid of them it
is amazing thing when you're in control
here you will save yourself your
insurance rate won't double and trible
as a result of getting a diagnosis
because you get the diagnosed you get
rid of the disease it's not in your
permanent medical record what a concept
okay let's see here Douglas go to
callers let's head to Detroit Michigan
and Anthony you're on with Dr wallik
Anthony you're on the air hey Dr W God
bless you um God bless you to Sir I've
got a young lady that's 59 220 lbs 44
years of age um she doesn't feel regular
with a diges system
um uh not too long ago she had surgery
on a obstructed
bowel and she's unable to get
pregnant um her doctor is also saying
that uh she might come down with
diabetes but her mom and dad doesn't
have diabetes never had it um K is not
genetic you know that doesn't matter if
Mom and Dad had her or not exactly she's
asthmatic um since three years old and
she has Arch problems with her right
foot ball with her right foot okay
that's it well that's it huh okay this
is a Char thing Miss Char are you there
I'm here okay dear okay this scal here
is 5 foot N9 weighs 220 lb so I would
say that she's probably 40 lbs
overweight okay or more 40 50 PBS
overweight she's got constipation uh she
has had asthma since she was a kid and
she's got
um let's see here um obstructed bowel
which could be something like um Crohn's
disease or something like that she got
typed to diabetes uh she's infertile and
arthritis she got problems with her
joints and Bones what would you say is
her basic underlying problem I know it's
a gluten intolerance I know it is you
get an A+ there dear exactly right
gluten intolerance so we need to get rid
of all the bad foods the fried foods
processed meets oils and gluten no wheat
brought around oats and then what kind
of program would you give her for for a
protocol for supplements oh I'd get her
on the healthy two healthy brain and
heart packs and then I would give her
you know she could take the um uh herbal
rainforest at night for a uh
constipation very good yeah I just start
out with just a tablespoon at night
which is a half ounce so one quart could
last two months uh and that should help
her with a softer regular stool okay and
then what would you do two healthy brain
and heart packs I'd give her some uh
swee EAS and then I would also give her
some uh gluco gel 15 gluc gel is two
large bottle month five five and five
sweetie that'd go ahead and give her
three twice a day or three three times a
day but there's one other thing we need
to do the weight loss thing and so hang
on we'll come back Anthony we'll give
you a piece add to the weight loss after
these messages you're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network with your host Dr Joel wallik if
you'd like to talk to Dr wallik call us
toll-free 888 379 2552 on the priority
line 831
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel wallik helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr wallik
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr wallik is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313 444
3463 that's 313 444
3463 call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 31 313 444
3463 that's 313 444
3463 call now to change your life that's
313 444
3463 hi this is Dr Joel Wallock your
host of Dead Doctors Don't Lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse blood
cleanse liver cleanse you know in the
classical herbal way you want to ask
your youngevity associate for Herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that and
your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rainforest I guarantee you it
will give you a cleanse you can control
the dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy nothing
better than a happy colon herbal
rainforest clean it up
for more information on this product or
others you've heard about on the Dead
Doctors Don't Lie radio program call
your local youngevity associate today
and don't forget to ask about homebased
business
opportunities greetings everyone Judy
dilus here what do you think of when you
hear the words Tangy Tangerine well I
think of like a sweet Tangy tasting
something well what I'm referring to is
the ultimate Tangy Tangerine it's a
fantastic product it has everything you
need and a great benefit is it's very
very delicious it's very easy to drink
I've suggested it even to youngsters
even children like it even little guys
even little girls they come right into
my office their parents can't get them
to take those chewables and besides that
they're not as good as tangy tangerine
and I give them a little taste of that
and you know something they're pleased
as punch so if it's good for a child and
it tastes delicious why not you there's
no excuse not to take a vitamin when it
tastes as good as that does so how about
it Tangy Tangerine should be the answer
answer to all of your nutritional
program problems for more information or
to order call your youngevity
distributor today and don't forget to
ask about youngevity homebased business
opportunities this is the zbs radio
network network network
[Music]
network
we're back with Dead Doctors Don't line
the zbs radio network Dr Jo wall here
for young 9 for live Crusade we do have
lines open give us a call tollfree one8
379 2552 again as toll free18 379
2552 and Douglas right back to Michigan
and Anthony with his ladyes problems
here and so what would you um also add
to this lady's program Charmaine to help
her lose lose at 40 PBS I would have her
get the
Rev okay rev it's a liquid dropper
bottle it's actually a a um second
generation of the ASAP as Slim as
possible soon as possible a REV and
we've revved it up so that's why they
changed the name to rev and um it's a
dropper bottle go ahead and get one of
those because it's one per 50 pounds of
body weight you need to lose per month
put a dropper full under this lady's
tongue she can put under her tongue 30
minutes for each meal leave it absorbed
through oral tissues um won't hurt her
if she swallows it but she won't get
maximum benefit and she will begin to
lose a half a pound of two pounds a day
when she achieves her ideal weight which
be say one um 165 to 180 somewhere in
there depending on if she's working out
or not um she can of course continue to
use the Rev you say three days a week
instead of all seven days and of
maintain what she's got but she needs to
maintain the 90 cents of nutrients and
give us a call every two weeks if you
would Anthony and we'll need to know her
blood pressure her blood sugar how much
she weighs um how she's doing with her
bowel movements how's her asthma going
all this kind of stuff but she's going
to do very very well because this is as
Char said is all due to nutritional
deficiencies malabsorption because of
the basic
underlying um gluten intolerance when
she's had since a child okay Doug let's
go to callers all right let's head to
Texas and Marissa you are on with Dr
wallik okay Marissa you're on the air hi
what's up hi I am calling actually on
recommendation of a family friend who
used your products as he had a surgery
for prostate cancer and he credits him
for reversing his cancer so my mother
has colon cancer she's 69 years old and
was diagnosed she's not doing chemo or
radiation we're trying to fight it
nutritionally um she has a large mask
that hasn't
metastasized and just to give you a
little bit of her medical history she
was diagnosed with diabetes around the
same time they found the mass her
fasting blood sugar is usually around
140 but it got as low as 104 earlier
this month she's anemic she has the
sickle cell trait she's had kidney
problems about 30 years ago she was
pling blood cots and the doctor told her
that was related to her kidneys she's
lost about 50 pounds since 2012 and
about 20 since having colostomy surgery
which was related to the cancer she has
a lot of moles on her face and neck
which I think May indicate a compromised
immune system since moles are similar to
wart she has one cap tooth and has lost
most of her teeth she started losing
them in her 20s she's on hydrocodone for
severe pain post colostomy surgery and
let's see um one of her children has
full bone sickle fail and one was born
with leaky gut if that gives you any
clues
and okay just how much does your mom how
much does your mom weigh she's 90 pounds
and she's about five five and a
half okay all right let's go with that
now she's got a lot of problems going on
here and she has one son who has
full-blown sickle cell is that correct a
daughter yes a daughter okay uh diabetes
um colon cancer and she's had a history
of kidney problems so this is a Shar
thing what's the basic underlying
problem here Charmaine a gluten
intolerance of course yeah gluten
intolerance of course all her children
including yourself this is your mom
yourself and all your siblings all your
brothers and sisters need to get Dro
dead gluten-free in your mama's
household this would include the dog the
cat the bird the fish spouse um any of
her siblings sisters or brothers renters
partner whatever's going on here got to
get the whole household gluten-free and
then we'll come back and Sh and I will
outline a protocol nutritional
supplement protocol for you to help your
mom's immune system which will be her
best friend at this point be back after
these messages you're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network with your host Dr Joel wall if
you'd like to talk to Dr Wall call us
toll-free 888
[Applause]
52 you've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel wallik helped many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Lie
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr wallik
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
Dr wallik is on to something and you
want to try youngevity's premium quality
products for yourself we can connect you
with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at 313 444
3463 that's 313 444
3463 call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 313 444
3463 that's 313 444
3463 call now to change your life that's
313 444
3463 I am Judy dilus here I am speaking
to you again I just wanted to tell you
that recently I started drinking the
waist shakes again the chocolate waist
shake and you need to remember the waist
Shake isn't just for losing weight it's
a fantastic place to get your great
protein and if you're trying to gain
weight you can take it along with your
meals and the best part is if you want
to just have a great protein shake do
like I do put it over ice Stir It Up and
you can sip on it for 20 minutes to an
hour I do it every single day I
absolutely love it you need to get back
to it too it's really good for you and
it makes not fat but it makes muscle
after you work out and you can also mix
it up in a blender with an egg and you
have the most incredible Health protein
shake or mix it with a little water
stirred up and you have a little pudding
and who doesn't like pudding for more
information or to order call your young
jevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about young jevity
homebased business
[Music]
opportunities
we're back with dead doline the zbs
radio network Dr Joel wall here
9528 we do have lines open give us call
toll free8 379 2552 that's toll-f free8
379 2552 and if you want to live to be
well beyond 100 chronologically say 110
120 130 140 150 160 170 180 190 100 plus
being biologically 30 40 50 people said
well come on wall there is no way well I
want you to remember Roger banister
before the 4minute mile was broken it
was totally impossible for a human being
with two legs only a horse with four
legs could do a four minute mile not a
human being and he broke it right during
the Olympics and thousands of people
broke it within six months after he
broke it because they knew it could be
done and they just worked a little
harder and made it happen well the same
thing is true watch it because we're
going to live there's a bunch of us
about a thousand of us have gotten
together we call it the 200 club and we
are going to live well beyond 200 and
guess what once we do it everybody on
Earth will see gosh we can do it don't
wait don't wait until it's too late for
you contact your young associate as for
the book epigenetics The Death of the um
genetic disease transmission the book
immortality and the book rare cures
learn how to add 25 to 50 Health years
to your life okay dougl let's go right
back to Texas and Marissa all right
sharmain what are we going to do um
let's see here for the for this woman
from a supplement
standpoint well she needs I would get
her on a a healthy brain and hard pack
and then she also needs a sweedies for
the kidney problems I'd give her the
daily classic the nin plus and the
cardio sticks okay now she does have a
master intestines what would you do to
help her immune system um shrink that
mass um she could take the BTT 2.0
tablets for for or points C points
right right get 160,000 that' be four of
those tablets a day two breakfast two at
dinner time that's one bottle a month
and there's a liquid quart it has few
covid in it what what would you give her
i' give her the Z radical for that
perfect you get an a triple plus very
good the Z radical it's a it's a liquid
comes in quartz um I'd go ahead and get
her two quarts of that Z like zebra Dash
and then radical because this is just
really really supports immune system
that's going be her best friend there
give us a call every a couple of weeks
if you would please
uh Marissa and we'll walk your ladies
through this okay Douglas go to callers
all right let's head to Illinois and
Brenda you're on with Dr wallik well
Brenda you're on the air how are you
fine how can we help you oh great I'm
calling for my daughter um this is her
situation she have not had a menstrual
cycle has not stopped the doctor prescri
wait a minute wait a minute you said two
different things here she's had a
continuous Cycles
right she have not stopped her menstrual
cycle okay okay okay her doctor
prescribed her or Tri cycling then he
then she uh prescribed her the uh
strenck St r i n t c birth control
appeals uh she was diagnosed from her
physi primary physician with uh uh
minoria me n o r a h a g i a yeah minia
that's a form of dis dis min yeah right
okay so she's 34 years old and this has
been going on in her since how much did
she weigh years
she wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute she's had problems
with her mro cycle since she's nine
years old 29 oh 29 okay 29 years old and
um how tall is she she's
5'3 okay 53 I'd like to see her way 115
so she needs lose almost you know 90 to
100 pounds here okay so uh Charmaine
what would you do for this lady well I
would say that she's because of the
weight problem she's got a gluten in
tance because you can absorb sugar but
you can't absorb
nutrients so what I would get her on I
would get her on two healthy brain and
heart packs but she can also and then
get her on the woman's FX and the
zero okay very very good and what would
you do for the weight we need her to
lose yeah the rev the Rev would get rid
of very good okay moar is exactly
correct uh your daughter's got to get
her dietary stuff changed she's got to
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
food remember this is everybody in the
household not just her no fried foods no
exceptions no processed Meats with
nitrates nitrites no Deli slices
sandwich meat sausage ham bacon baloney
salami pami pepperoni jerky Carn beef
spam all that kind of stuff absolutely
no oils no olive oil coconut oil
margarin man cooking oils absolutely no
gluten no gluten even in the dog food
cat food food fish food no gluten no
weat B ran oats that's got to go and
then AAR said I'd have her take two
healthy branded heart packs per month I
would
um also um let's see here um does she
have any joint problems or high blood
pressure
diabetes well she's on the uh women's
effects and the extra and the uh ex
extra appeals from you she's been taking
that okay okay now is she taking okay
she taking the the healthy brain heart
packs and 90 cents of
nutrients no she's not taking those okay
well well she's got to take those
otherwise the other two aren't going to
work very well okay she needs two
healthy brained heart packs as sh said a
full dose from of breakfast and dinner
she can take three of those zerm tablets
twice be two bottles a month she needs
uh two ounces of the woman's FX an ounce
of breakfast oun in quart bottle so it
take two quarts a month and then but
it's imperative for her to give up the
gluten so she going to absorb all this
stuff and then the Rev or EV i' have her
take an ounce 30 minutes for each meal
and have her take an ounce 15 minutes
for each meal so it'll be two bottles a
month pull that off and she will begin
to lose the weight and um it doesn't
take long once the nutrition begins to
seep through uh I would also get her on
how many eggs a day would you have her
eat Charmaine to make sure she's can
make enough hormones oh at least six to
eight eggs a day yeah I per 100 pounds
of body weight so she needs 12 to 16
eggs a day now why do you think that the
that the
um uh birth control pills didn't work so
she's not absorbing them you got it A++
yeah she couldn't absorb even the birth
control pills that's why it didn't help
her much so it's imper to get rid of all
the bad stuff the fried foods the
processed Me O and gluten then call US
every couple of weeks let us know her
weight um let us know her uh blood
pressure uh we need to know um how her
Cycle's going see the reason why she's
not seeing much success here she's not
absorbing these things she can as Char
said she can absorb calories which are
very small particles only five to six
carbons long very easy to absorb sugar
and carbohydrates it's difficult to
absorb these nutrients when you have a
gluten problem and you're eating gluten
no gluten there is no such thing as
gluten-free oats you cannot have oatmeal
for breakfast no wheat BR R oats no
exceptions okay Doug let's see if we can
start another one all right let's head
to Chicago Illinois and Dave you're on
with Dr Wallock oh Dave you're on the
air yes Dr Wallock I have a gentleman
who is five six and 180 lounds and he's
uh 50 uh 50 years
old he's got that he has had diabetes uh
for some time already and he got some
problem with his eyes he's uh got gloma
in one eye and he's also had some
problems with the uh other eye but
recently he's been seeing uh flashes on
his eye that he don't on the side he
doesn't see because of Thea okay I I
missed that I missed that wait a minute
I didn't hear what you said I heard
something in the eye but I didn't get
what he's got in that eye okay on the
eye from the eye that he's got gloma
answer sir he's seeing some um flashing
and he says he sees images of people
moving that are not when when when
there's no people there okay there's all
right got that all right does he have
anything else does he have um arthritis
does he have high blood
pressure diabetes uh dry skin
constipation I know he's got a gluten
tolerance problem I know that yes okay
okay here we go okay Charmaine everybody
knows he's got a gluten intolerance so
he's got to get rid of all the bad food
so what would you
do well I would get him on uh two
healthy brain and heart packs and add
the sweedies to it and i' get him on the
utive and the vision
FX okay what did you do to get blood
flowing properly in the eye I get him on
the ultimate daily classic the plus and
the cardio sck okay you get an A+ deer
okay you know what to do Dave give us a
call every couple weeks on this guy
because he should see some great
improvements particularly immediately in
his diabetes yeah I think it'll take a
little bit longer but it'll help too we
back with Dead Doctors Don't Lie for
these messages you're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network with your host Dr Joel
[Music]
wallik imagine a rich decadent chocolate
that's actually good for you young jeevi
triple treat chocolate is just that an
antioxidant-rich dark chocolate complete
with probiotics to Aid in proper
digestion this allnatural product
contains no preservatives and for those
with dietary restrictions it's
gluten-free dairyfree glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate taste
fantastic it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an oric value of6
936 per piece triple treat chocolate
also contains a proprietary blend of
probiotics with over 500 million live
healthy bacteria per 8 grams at the time
of manufacturer with 80% reaching the
intestines which is much more than most
live culture yogurts if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about homebased business
opportunities hey if you're like me your
life is hectic you don't know where
you're going to be next between kids and
family and in-laws and work and traffic
and everything else that's driving me
crazy right now my life is insane I bet
your life's insane as well when do we
have time to get every single nutrient
we need to be healthy when well I've got
a tip for you take a product called
pollen burst it's so simple even I can
do it all you have to do is open the
package pour it in water mix it up and
Bam you're ready to go it tastes great
it's not one of those medicine tasting
things it tastes great low in calories
helps curb your appetite gives you
Natural Energy that doesn't let you
crash gives you your vitamins minerals
nutrients everything from the plant
world and I got to tell you for a busy
person like me or a busy person like you
we need simple we need good pollen bur
is your answer taste great try it and
you'll feel better call your local
youngevity distributor to find out how
pollen burst can make you feel better
and don't forget to ask about home-based
business
opportunities you've listened to
physician and veterinarian Dr Joel wall
helped many people on the Dead Doctors
Don't Lie talk radio program you've also
heard hundreds of people tell how Dr
wallik and youngevity products have
changed their lives if you're now
convinced that Dr wallik is on to
something and you want to try
youngevity's premium quality products
for yourself we can connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 313 444
3463 that's 313 444 4
3463 call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly remember the phone
number 313 444
3463 that's 313 444
3463 call now to change your life that's
313 444
[Music]
we're back lbs radio network wall here
Crusade and Doug let's go to callers
let's head to Indiana and Stanley you're
on with Dr wallik Stanley you're on the
air all right thanks Doc I'm uh having
trouble focusing and making decisions I
kind of go into like a la la land or I
have no urgencies and nothing
you know it's like somebody's changing
channels in my mind over and over and
over every couple of minutes okay now
are you are you on any medication for
depression or anything like that no I'm
not I've tried them okay they seem to
help a little bit initially and then
they Pro my prostate you know gets where
I can't pee and sure this makes me
miserable okay so uh do you have any
history of asthma as a
kid yes I was born with uh asthma a
fever sinuses and all kinds of allergies
I was Bor a blue b what about skin pums
okay what about skin pums any ezema
dermatitis rosacea not egit I've had
like psoriasis basil cells and stuff and
you know no psorasis some skin issue
okay about what about what about bow
problems constipation
diarrhea uh it kind of very seldom have
constipation but it does go into soft
toel or diarrhea quite frequent okay
alternates okay yeah it Al all right
what do you we sir uh 165 how tall are
you six foot okay all right well having
these sorts
of um which I say disturbances with sort
of brain function if you will uh how the
brain works and interprets in the
environment so forth is a nutritional
deficiency okay it's not anything inborn
or anything like that this is aut Nu
deficiency because you're all right for
most of your life you know in the last
couple years you had these problems
nutritional deficiency and so Charmaine
What's um Stanley's basic problem here
um he has a gluten intolerance for sure
oh absolutely okay very very good and so
what would you give him beside no fried
food no processed Meats no oils no
gluten no wheat R around oats what would
you give him as a protocol I give him
two healthy brain and heart packs
synaptive and
d-stress
okay oh that's very good the d-stress
absolutely and let's see
here I think no that's very good I think
you got it all girl yeah so two Heather
branded heart packs a month that's a
full dose everything twice a day and
then the synaptive I'd go ahead and take
two of those tablets twice a day it'll
be two bottles a month this is the raw
materials for um making
neurotransmitters so one nerve cell can
talk to the other and Char is exactly
correct the Dess capsules capital D like
David D and this has to do with the
metabolism in the brain how it functions
and how it works and so forth and all of
these various things you've had as a
younger person asthma bowel problems
alternating diarrhea a little bit of
constipation once in a while skin issues
um of various kinds these are all drop
dead gluten intolerance indicators okay
so yourself spouse partner mother-in-law
renter dog cat bird fish siblings kids
in the house everybody's got to be Dro
dead gluten-free otherwise you're not
glutenfree because of
cross-contamination of the laundry cross
contamination on the couch everybody
watches TV C bed sleep together food
preparation Services laundry again it's
imperative that everybody is dropped
that gluten-free that's going to um make
sure you're going to efficiently absorb
this stuff uh because um uh these things
are easily dealt with but of course um
as you found out these these
anti-depressive drugs really aren't
going to help the problem because
there's no nutrition in an
anti-depressive drug okay you really
need the nutrition and Char's outlined a
very very good program for complete
brain nutrition and so give us a call if
you would because you're suffering from
things that millions of Americans suffer
from so you'd be a great testimony if
you would call us every two weeks and
give us a a progress report or lack of
progress report we can help you tweak
things make sure it works and we look
forward to hearing from you it'll be a
wonderful thing to share with everybody
else and um do call us like I say every
two weeks or so you're welcome to call
anytime if you have a question but don't
wait longer than two weeks because
you're going to have a following of
people who want to hear what you got to
say because there are millions of people
suffering from the same things you are
okay Doug how much time we got here will
that answer that
[Music]
question all right well thank you so
much everybody we had some great
testimonies and questions today thank
you Char super a plus job today thank
you Doug and Sams you PR job as usual
God bless each and every one of you God
bless our troops God bless our Navy
Seals and God bless
[Music]
America
y